What a character chooses to drink says a
lot about them,
about teenage shaken.
If they get a shot of whiskey,
they're cool.
If they order a fine chardonnay,
they're probably trying to go for class,
but there's wondrich used in cinema that
requires a bit of explanation as to
drinking 1% is that because you think
you're fat?
Probably the first thing that comes to
mind when you think of milk is youth and
innocence.
When a 16 year old uses his charm and
grace to mimic being a pilot,
we're reminded of his age by his drink
of choice.
Would you like a drink after takeoff
milk in a clockwork orange,
the adolescent streak mill,
a gentle reminder that all this mayhem
is being caused by kids.
James Deane,
famously nurses,
a bottle of milk in such a way that we
get a visual cue of his conflicts
between maturity and adulthood.
Of course,
if you don't drink milk,
then your manly,
Oh God,
am I outside them?
I I got a bowler nails for breakfast
this morning.
Yes,
so without an ame milk,
the right this wig,
sorry to keep you waiting.
If you want to go for a deep reading,
you could say that Kevin's spilling milk
in home alone is a symbol of his lack of
maternal nourishment.
Or You could say John Hughes just wanted
the visual joke of everybody crying over
spilled milk,
but this only scratches the surface.
Many adults also drink milk and that's
where it gets more complicated.
Milk is a symbol of childishness,
so it's humorous to see Leon,
the professional,
a hypermasculine assassin,
drinking it throughout the movie.
It fits into the comedic moments of the
movie,
but it also sheds light on his maternal
side as he takes Matilda under his wing.
In this instance,
drinking milk is a joke,
but many times drinking milk has the
opposite intent.
It's creepy.
There's something off about a grown man
drinking milk and filmmakers seem to be
well aware of this intuition in
hitchcock suspicion.
The audience suspects that the milk may
be poisoned.
It's an eerie choice to have milk,
a drink we associate with innocence and
purity be the drink that may be
poisoned.
I don't think it would have had nearly
the same effect if it were a cup of
coffee or a shot of whiskey.
There's something delightful about
making milk threatening.
We see this again and inglorious
bastards.
Colonel Hans Londa chugs a glass of milk
from Lofa deeds farm and it has the
creepy factor,
but there's more to it than that.
I quote a social theorist,
Roland barthes and his take on milk.
It's purity associated with the
innocence of a child is a token of
strength of a strength,
which is not revulsive,
not congestive,
but calm white,
lucid.
The equal of reality.
Me,
you have a wash
should cover.
So when a villain grabs the glass of
milk,
it's creepy,
but it also shows their power.
They're conquering the pure and innocent
by consuming it and there's a strength
to that.
When I saw Mad Max fury road in
theaters,
the only time people audibly cringed in
the crowd wasn't during an action
sequence.
It was when this happened,
Western culture has an aversion to
breastmilk,
seeing it as taboo to drink as an adult.
It's a little wonky.
That's because that's from Debbie's left
breast.
Greg,
the choice to harvest breast milk in the
movie further alienates the post
apocalyptic world from our own.
In short,
Mad Max fury road is a movie about
fluids.
Women are exploited for their breast
milk.
Men are exploited for their blood and
the populous is exploited by controlling
the water supply.
The complete control of these liquids by
a Wharton Joe shows his dominion over
his world and the milk is no exception.
In fact,
his sons drink the milk to keep up their
muscle mass.
Reinforcing the idea that consuming milk
is a sign of strength.
What's so great about using these
liquids in the film is that it allows
mad max to introduce plot points and
character arcs non verbally.
After Mad Max performance,
his first selfless act for Furiosa,
he washes himself with milk symbolizing
the start of his transformation from a
selfish man only looking for survival to
one who cares in nurtures for others,
the turn to completely trusting Furiosa
is symbolized by him giving her his
blood.
Another liquid symbol,
mad max fury road is a prime example of
milk.
Enhancing the visual storytelling of a
movie.
Milk is a powerful storytelling device.
It can show someone as a child,
but it can also be used to unsettle show
character strength or give information
about the plot.
So the next time you see a character
drinking something,
ask yourself,
thanks for one,
whoever it is,
a cool,
slightly trends full,
just a bit of a break from the norm.
Just a little slump in the break from
monotony of all that hard.